okay my dollar store closed by me here
in hollywood and i was like oh my gosh
the economy's gotten bad when my dollar
store closes that's your litmus test for
the
economy
okay but everything's been going up
electricity and all that so i have to i
would have to say like i understand
dollar store i understand would you ever
run for office to make changes in a like
in l.a yeah i actually said like with my
one-year anniversary about my sexual
assault i actually like empower other
victims of assaults to actually run for
like office positions um so that way
like we can improve
i don't know consent culture and laws
and just bettering our lives you know
like be office managers or you mean like
uh
do you want to announce something on
here do you want to are you looking for
any political like do you think in the
future yes i think once i get my public
affairs and law degree done
i feel like i will totally be ready to
help support so many people and be hated
by people for helping our economy but i
think i just want that degree for people
and their sanity would it be in
california that you would run it could
be in california or it might be in texas
i was actually a little bothered by like
last time voting on the ballot i was
like seeing like cashier clerks
like running our city or like whatever
the government or the governor position
so i think that's why i am kind of being
very serious about my schooling so i'm
credible
so but what so tell me what you would
politically what are what are your what
is your interest
like what what do you want to do
do you have it that's the limit you know
you have a solution for our economy
i love economics
so
i i mean i'm not gonna like do my
political stand i'm not gonna do my
campaign on a podcast but
when i am fortunate to be in a position
that i can help others um
i would definitely
probably be like
over a district
i don't know if i would ever do governor
um
congress person i like congress um
senator
president you like president
you know there's a lot of i don't know
why there's just such a hateful
connotation around being a president
anymore
so i would like to say president
positive president but i also think like
being in the senate being in congress
they are voting a lot for a lot of
things that affect us
um so i often see like congress and the
senate are affecting like the president
so i just feel like there's so many
seats there's so many seats there yeah
why not take a seat so
i like that
i like that so you heard it here first
on howie mandel does stuff congress
we're doing stuff right we are doing
stuff
the senate bears in this there's so many
seats
farrah is going to take a seat yes thank
you i hope you know i love that line
well i'm i'm going to make it the i'm
going to make that announcement on this
podcast and then when it comes true i i
i i appreciate you making the
announcement right here plant those
seeds comedy plant ted talk
law degree and then the senate
i love this thank you yeah organizing it
for someone adhd i like it i like lists
we have a brand new mom and whiteout
white out
yeah no one's gonna get my sheets no
one's gonna get my records it's all
white out okay i love the idea oh yeah
baby pencil that in
pencil that in we are making so many
announcements so many historic
announcements today
[Music]
you